Evet evet ekşi maya ekmek yapmayan
kalmamıştır diye düşünüyorum Bir sürü
Herkes evde gördüğüm ve izlediğim
kadarıyla ekmekler hamurişleri hatta
biraz daha zorladığım zaman Kral sana
kadar yapan güzel insanlar tanıdım biraz
da hani erkekler evde işte et pişirme
barbekü taktiklerine girdi ama bu da
tabi iyi geldi Niye iyi geldi Çünkü
yemek yaparken beş duyumuzun aynı anda
çalışıp zihninizin boşalttığı tek şey bu
vücudunuza en iyi gelen şey bu Beş
duyumuz aynı anda çalışıyor şimdi biraz
kandilinin başlarına ya da bu sürece
geri dönelim bu süreç içerisinde
ekmeklerimizi yaptığımız zamana gidelim
biraz bu ekmeği yaparken ne kadar zaman
harcadığımızı bir geri dönelim bu
yaklaşık 8 saatte yapan var reçete oku
72'ye kadar çıkan var o
Az önce Maya mızı kuruyoruz sonra ona
tatlı tatlı isim veriyoruz sonra böyle
elimizdeki bakterilerle onu bekliyoruz
duygusal bir bağımız muhakkak var tabii
ekmek oluyor Kimimiz Karakılıç akkılık
buğday kullanıyor Kimimiz ekşi maya için
diye buğdayları kaliteli Buğdaylar
vesaire yoğuruyoruz bunun için gerçekten
çok ciddi bir emek harcıyoruz Ama daha
sonra pişmesini bekliyoruz aslında Kısa
sürede pişiyor ama yüksek derecelik
fırında pişiyor bu süreç içerisinde
kimimizin biraz elektrik faturaları
kabarmış olabilir bunun süresinde ama
işin sonunda mis kokulu kendi elinizin
ürünü Şahane ekmekler çıkıyor ortaya
Şimdi biz Ellerine sağlık yapmaya devam
ediyorsunuz bunu da biliyorum artık
dışarıdan takıda almıyoruz ve hayatımız
Bununla ilgili değişiyor dedik bu
pandemi den sonra hayatımız biraz daha
değişiyor bize Mutfaktayız Kimimiz ne
güzel evden online çalış abi
Her Yaşta güzel gelmişti bu tabi herkese
şimdi ne kadar güzel tartışılır ama biz
online çalışamıyoruz hocam gene
mutfaklar dayız Üstüne üstlük 16 saat 14
saat kimi zaman 21 saati bulan çalışma
koşullarımız var çok çalışkan ve keyifli
bir ekiple çalıştım bu süreç içerisinde
çok gurur duyuyorum hepsine teker teker
Ama bu kadar yoğunluk içerisinde bir de
ağzımızda maske ile çalışmak zorunda
kalıyoruz mutfak zaten sıcak video Bu
biraz bizim için açıkçası yorucu oluyor
ama gene de bu bizim mesleğimiz bu bizim
işimiz ama en önemlisi Gıda bizim
hayatımızın en temel ihtiyaçlarından
biri Çünkü unutmayalım yemek ilk
zamanlardan biri en iyi sosyalleşme
aracı bizim hayatımızda Peki bu süreç
içerisinde bizim terminoloji miz ufak
değişmeye başladı bu neler girdi
hayatımıza şimdi bir kerede
bu işaret girdi Bunlar gibi gene de
oğlumu GDO suz mu hibrit tohumu hocam
yüzdeyüz organik köyden geldi Bunların
hepsi ama hepsi artık bizim dilimizde
markete gittiğimiz zaman gene artık
alışkanlıkla kalıyor arkasına bakıyoruz
nereden geldi herkes evine sanırım
Ayvalık'tan zeytinyağlarını söyledi
tersten gravyer peyniri de geliyordur
işte Elazığ'dan pestiller falan onları
Hayır Van'dan çok severiz Ama doğrusu
tamamından gelmesi lazım Kimisi maydanoz
dereotu koyu ona doğru peynir diyor
Dolayısıyla sütü organik almaya
çalışıyoruz Kimimiz kendi evimizde kendi
peynirimizi yapıyoruz ama önce dikkat
ettiğim şeyler artık bunlar Çünkü
hepiniz evde gıda Hazırladığınız ve
artık doğru gıdaya ulaşmanın ne kadar
zor olduğunu bunun artık pahada biraz
kıymetli olduğunu ve Biz anladık
ve dolayısıyla tatlı tatlı
emekliliğinizi Beklerken gerekli
yatırımları gerek yere yaparken
hayallerimizden biri Ayvalık'ta Bahçeli
bir ev Erdek olur Sarımsaklı ya da
nereye seviyorsanız tabi arkasına bir
bahçe yapmak değil mi kendim ekleyeceğim
kendim bitireceğim toprağa dokunacağım
Çünkü özümde bu var kendim ekleyeceğim
ve kendim bitireceğim bu kısmı tekrar
konuşacağız ama işin sonunda kendi
evinizin hasadını toplayacaksınız ve
bunu kendi soframıza taşıyacaksınız bir
kere insan olmanın gerektirdiği en güzel
şeylerden biri bu olabildiğince kendi
ürünü toplama ve Tabiki Bahçeli Bir Ev
Hayali En sevdiğimiz Dolayısıyla artık
ne hibrit tohumu dura tohumu nedir ufak
biliyoruz bunu Peki yatırımları yaptık
dedik doğru geleceğimizi ona göre
şekillendirmeye çalışıyoruz Bu doğru ki
ne yapacağız bunu da
bu bankalar artık tohum Bankası bankalar
bir tanesi Biga resimde gördüğünüz
Şimdilik bilmemiz gereken bu diğeri de
Norveç'te ve çok ciddi olanda tüm
dünyada tohum toplanıyor Çünkü böyle
giderse biz gerçekten likit olarak şeydi
gıdamız kalmayacak elimizde Ben çocukken
kınalıada'da büyüdüm orada Çocukken
tattığım bir sürü Deniz ürünlerini şimdi
zaten göremiyorum ismini bile bile
rabbinedir Çaça nedir Bunları bile
unuttu yeni sildim ama temel olarak Hani
ekmek de de gıda da şeyde tohumları
tutmazsak daha az önce sohbet ediyorduk
Datça'da da zebra domatesi gitgide
azalmış bitmek üzere Gibi Gibi Bu
bankanın ne kadar önemli olduğunu
unutmamamız gerekiyor Yani yaptığınız
şeylerin en temelinde bu var şimdi biz
elimiz
bu ne kadar taşın altına koyacağız biz
bu tohumları ne kadar korumaya devam
edeceğiz ne kadar menşeili aldığınız
ürünün menşei nereli Ben niye Dışarıdan
yemek gıda tüketiyorum asıl onlara
bakmamız gerekiyor ve bunun için en
temel de kendinizi sorular sormanız
gerekiyor ve kendinizi keşfetmeniz
gerekiyor Şu Ben aşçıyım bunda da çok
mutlu oluyorum Çünkü bu benim hayat
yolum ben bu işi seviyorum sevdiğim için
işi yaptığım için de çok şanslıyım
Açıkçası bu süreç içerisinde kendimizi
bir nötralize etmeye boşaltma için bir
sürü hobiler edindik ya da vardı bunu
öne çıkardık Kimimiz Hoca'nın yaptığı
gibi gitar çalıyoruz Kimimiz fotoğraf
çekiyoruz Kimimiz deli gibi yazıyoruz
kimiz kitap okuyoruz Kimimiz çok tatlı
patikleri ürünleri yapıyoruz evde
cookie'ler yapıyoruz popüler
hazırlıyoruz ve işin sonunda bana çok
tatlı mesajlar geliyor mesela belki
yapma
Sağ ol hocam dükkan açayım mı Ne
diyorsun Dükkanı açsınlar mı sen onları
evet diyorsun Tabii ki Onlar geliyorlar
istifa ediyorlar ağabey Yani o şey var
aman önce onu diyeyim lütfen kutu
yapmaya devam edin Dükkanı açın ama hani
10-15 tane değil yüz tane yapabiliyor
musunuz aynı Reçeteye dekametre biliyor
musunuz sabah 5'te kalka biliyor musunuz
ekşi maya gösterdiğiniz özeni kendi ufak
ürünlerinize de yapabiliyor musunuz bunu
bir sınıf geçiş olarak yapabilirsiniz
dükkan Tabii ki de açın Neden
açmıyorsunuz yani hani Fakat bu hayat
bize bildiklerimizi ufak ufak
değiştiriyor bunun en temel en keyifli
örneklerinden biri Bu en sevdiğim filmin
sahnelerinden Biri budur Şimdi evde
sadece ekmek yapmadık Yani bir sürü ürün
değiştirdik en güzeli turşulama ydı
orada çok sıkıntı var ya orada bir oraya
bir çözebilir miyiz çözebiliriz limonlu
sirke boyaması kim hocam Yuvam
Evet Ee Hiçbiri bu da olabilir tabii
Çünkü çok kıymetli organik sirke yapan
dostlarım var emeklileri alıntı ellerine
sağlık Ama o değil dünya değişiyor lafla
fermente dönüyoruz tuz ve su Aslında
yüzümüze dönüyoruz tuşuna Mada her şeyde
olduğu gibi Binlerce yıl öncesindeki
gibi tutuyoruz da gayet lezzetli oluyor
içerisinde bir iki garnitür sevdiğimiz
aromatik baharatlar ve kendi tuşlarını
kendimiz yapıyoruz Hayat Buna göre
dönüyor Hiçbir şey eskisi gibi
bildiğimiz gibi kalmıyor bu süreç
içerisinde şimdi süreç devam ederken Biz
ufak ufak kendimizi keşfettik ben de
kendimi keşfettim verelim sana bir yemek
kamyonlar benim fakat bir de tıkanan
vardı fakat Bununla ilgili bir keşifin
de oldu resimde görüyorsunuz piknik
bengo dükkan
ben kapattım gireceğim bu Ha onu
soracaktım ya Çok mutlu görünüyor seni
açtı günü kapattın gibi kapattığım gün
hocam Çünkü çok tatlı olarak baktım
sıfır ciro tabi sıfır o günü bu gülüşün
hocan abi çekti bunu moda olsun onu da
cebimize dolduralım neden eksik olmasın
çünkü kendinize ilgili keşfettiğim
şeylerden biri şu çok saygı duyarak bu
süreçte de canını dişine takarak çalışan
kendi dükkanını açıkta tutmaya çalışan
insanlar var Ben kendimle ilgili fark
ettim ki ben 21 saat mutfakta aşçı
olarak çalışabilirim ama ben dükkancı
değilim şimdi keşfedip yaptık Az önceki
arkadaşlar da ne olur ki de aç ya da ne
olur sevdiğin işi burgerci etmemin
sebebi şu kendini keşfet Ben o değilim
İyi ki açtın mı İyi ki açtım İyi ki
yaptığımı iyi ki yaptım Bir de olsa bir
de yapar mıyım Bir de olsa büyük bir
daha yapalım bunu keşfetmek için çok
eğlenceli bir dükkanda bunun için
temelinde Seninle konuştuğumuz
sohbetlerin birinde hayatın boyunca
unutma
ya bir soru sordum Sen bana dedin ki 8
yaşındaki Tamer ye dönüp sorsam bu
yaşındaki tam eridikten mutlu Ama ben
evet sekiz yaşında değil Biraz da ufak
varyasyonun buradaki resimdeki Halim çok
eğlenceli partiler gibi deli biraz
buradaki deliğe soracak olsan ben
kendimle ilgili Evet bu tam eridikten
mutluyum Bu tam Aşkta gurur duyuyorum ve
gönül rahatlığıyla iyi ki yapmışım
diyebilirim Çünkü denedim yanıldım
düştüm kalktım pandemi ile beraber dünya
değişirken bir sürü bir sürü şey
öğrendim ceplerime bunları doldurdum Ama
geri dönüp buradaki halimi de şimdi
burada seninle konuşurken ki halime de
bakınca tek bir şey diyorum hocam Benim
iyikilerim keşkelerim den fazla bunu
yaparken bunu kendi kendime sorarken
illa billah herhangi bir yerde durup
kendi kendime dinleme zamanı yapma
şu an Dolayısıyla herkes büroda durup
kendi iç sesin yankılanması beklemeden
bu soruyu kendisine sonra şu şahane bir
soru bu durup durup arada bir durmamız
gerektiğini söyledi Hoca çok doğru durup
durup kendimize sormamız gerektiği soru
bu ben bu durumda mutluyum ben bir aşçı
olarak Az önce bahsettiğim gibi sadece
bıçağını tahtam ürün geldi işledim bu
gidiyor devam etsin hayır hayat böyle
devam etmeyecek Ben bir meslekteki Tamer
ilk olarak kişisel olarak da kendine
mutluyum doğru yerde miyim dünyaya ayak
uydurabilir muyum onu kendinle ilgili
sormam gerekiyor Dolayısıyla Sizlerden
ricam Ara ara lütfen kendinize durup
Birkaç soru sorun birincisi de lütfen
karbon üzerinize Bakın bu çevreyi ne
kadar kirletiyoruz ne kadar kil
etmiyoruz bu ürünleri ne kadar daha
devam ettireceğiz ne kadar daha
ettiremeyecek Siz bunları bir dönüp
bakalım lütfen ve lütfen
ve yerel üreticilerin ve Ürünleri
destekleyelim yani Eskiden çocukken
hepimiz işte manavuz vardı Kendi
kasabamız vardı organik sütümüz vardı
yani organik olan şey olan olması
gereken şey şu anda güçlü olduğu bir
süreçte yiz Bunun kıymetini pandemi daha
iyi anladım Çünkü hepiniz gidip gıda
satın almaya başladığınız artık hazır
Evet tabakları masaların önüne
tabakların gelmesi güzel yemek yemekten
çok güzel vakit alıyorsunuz güzel
sohbetler etmekten de vakit alıyorsunuz
Ama artık pandemi nedeniyle uzun
sofralar kuramıyoruz dilerim bir an önce
kurmaya başlarız o ayrı ama lütfen ve
lütfen yerel üreticileri destekleyelim
ve üçüncüsü mevsiminde ve kararında
tüketelim tek bir şey rica ediyorum
lütfen şu aralar közde patlıcan salatası
yemeyelim hocam enginar yemeyelim 12 ay
olması bizi ilgilendirmiyor 12 ay olması
gereken şey olması gereken şey değil
özlemle b
ve temiz bir çilek var yok şu anda 12 ay
bulabiliyorsunuz lütfen közde patlıcan
salatasını yazın yiyin şu an kerevizde
idare edebilir O da güzel bir sebze yani
ya da olabildiğince ve kararında
tüketelim gelecek nesli düşünerek
hareket edelim Olur mu yani daha böyle
devam edersek az önceki bahsettiğimiz
konuda kendi Bahçenizde satın
alabilirsiniz kendi keyfinizi Bununla
ilgili yapabilirsiniz ama ekecik ne
kadar doğum bulacaksınız Bununla ilgili
lütfen kendinize Bu konuyla ilgili
sorular sordu ben evet Dayımın yanında
yetiştim bunu da gurur duyuyorum kendi
kültürümü olabildiğince yansıtmaya
çalışıyorum yediğim gıdaları bıçağı
çocukken yediği hala Yemeğe çalışıyorum
ama mesela dayımın bana söylediği çok
güzel bir cümle var o da şu şu yavrum
yayanın bilmediği yemekleri
da çıkmadı Şimdi yanında beraber en
sevdiğim ve Gene yemek yerken ki
resimlerinden biri bi Evet yayamın
bilmediği yemekleri çok fazla yememeye
çalışıyorum yani olabildiğince Anadolu
topraklarında yetişen bu toprakların
Melek etini daha çok farkında olmamı
sağlayan bu gıdaları daha çok tüketmeye
çalışıyorum ve bunları arkadaşlarıma
yani bize değil de güzel yemek yemeyi
seven arkadaşlarıma olabileceği onu
affettirmeye çalışıyorum çünkü gerçekten
eerrr zamanında dokunuşları yapmazsak
Eğer gerçekten ürünü zamanında
tüketmezsek lütfen gıdaya olduğu gibi
saygı göstermezsek Biz yaralarımızın
yediklerini yemeyeceğiz kendinize çok
dikkat ettiğinizi biliyorum Doğru
beslenmeye çalıştığınızda farkındayım
ayır verdik beslenmeden
o Sensiz rafine şekersiz bunları yapmaya
devam edin Evet şimdi ayda seviyoruz
hocam avokado Duygu seviyorsun avokado
da seviyoruz O da canımız ama ne kadar
tüketmemiz gerektiğini ne kadar bizim
vücudumuza uygun onu Bilmemiz gerekiyor
Yani yayma bilmediğim bildiği şeyler
derken ben canım isli firik bulguru da
unutmayalım Es geçmeyelim yani onlar da
Şahane şeyler kilo da çok güzel çiyanın
Hastasıyız onu da yiyoruz ayrı bir şey
Ama biz önce kendi olduğunu süreç
içerisinde kendimize ve bu sürece bu
gıdaya dikkat edelim olabildiğince be
zamanında ve yerinde beslenelim kendi
modum yay ama bilmediği emeklilik hepsi
her şey tadına bakıyorum hocam aramayı
Seki deformasyonu ayrı bir şey ama
olabildiğince öyle beslenelim zamanı
geldiğinde e
en iyi beslenirsek iyi bir şekilde devam
edeceğiz ve bizim yediğimiz şeyleri
diğer varyasyonları diğer yeni nesilde
yiyebilecek bizim görevimiz Bu aşamada
aşçı olarak iyi bir insan olarak ya da
Çevresine duyarlı insanlar olarak doğru
zamanda doğru şeyleri tüketmek ve
olabildiğince korumak tabi vaktinde ve
kararında yaştan hocam